I'm gonna find why
- xfinity and beyond this be forces a
little bit of a crazy place whatever how
while he's trapped and I'm gonna free
her of the hero out there
I'm learning your lesson Barry we can
[Music]
holy crap everybody we got to talk about
this flash footage let's break it down
there's a new flash ring giveaway going
on now all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so let's start this black flash
speedforce wormhole aliens therapy
session that's what happens every time
Barry goes into the Speed Force this is
just like runaway dinosaur last year he
got turned into pure energy trying to
reignite his Speed Force powers got
sucked into the Speed Force only to find
out that he never really lost his powers
to begin with they got really meta with
it they did not explain the Speed Force
at all you almost come out of that
episode knowing less about it than you
knew going in and that's kind of the
point they want to keep it really
nebulous so they can use it as a story
device however they want but that's
where the comics come in so what they're
doing here is sort of like a mix on the
idea of Full Metal Alchemist the law of
equal exchanges so sabot R is exchanged
for Wally like Jay Garrick says as the
black flash is sort of like wrapping his
fingers around Barry's throat every
marathon has a finish line what he's
talking about is Barry's death so in the
comics I mean the Speed Force has
changed a lot depending on who's writing
the comic book but originally like where
most of this story lines being taken
from the Mark Waid era the Speed Force
is where speedsters go when they die
it's their version of heaven they become
pure energy so the finish line they're
referring to is his death like he will
ultimately die I know we all think about
the future newspaper flash vanishes in
crisis it's almost like Barry's
sacrificing himself to save everyone
else likes avatar was calling him
selfish you're petty you only think of
yourself so what is the most selfless
thing you could do you could give your
life to save everyone else that was one
of his biggest regrets at the beginning
of season two that Ronnie died giving
himself to save them all so what a
coincidence that he's confronted with
all the people who gave their lives
selflessly to save everyone else while
Barry got to selfishly keep on living so
first we see Eddie we know that he's
back in this episode he confronts Barry
although really it's a Speed Force
wormhole alien confronting Barry with
his own weaknesses then you see Ronnie
it's so awesome to see him back in the
same episode we knew he was coming back
for a guest spot but we didn't know how
it was going to work now we know he's
another character who gave His life
selflessly so that everyone could live
in the baby that Caitlyn is holding that
might be the baby that she was going to
have with Ronnie had he lived because
the whole scene here like the common
denominator seems like people that died
during season one so that Barry could go
on being a hero but now you have sabot
are throwing that in his face so that is
probably a really big clue about
Savatage identity in the fact that he
was trapped in energy form and could
only come out when someone replaced him
maybe that means that he is part speed
force wormhole alien and there are rules
governing how they can exist in the real
world there are a lot of rules that the
show seems to be setting up with this
avatar plotline they haven't totally
explained it yet so I know a lot of you
are asking if he is the future flash
from the comics because he keeps calling
himself I am the future flash but the
punctuation and the phrasing that he's
using is very ambiguous so he could be
talking about him just being the new
world order or he could be a future
version of somebody that we know right
now like Barry himself or Wally but the
real thing that threw us for a loop that
really like threw a wrench and as the
theorycrafting was when he said that he
created himself
so like when while I get sucked in and
he comes out the theories blew wide open
so there are a whole lot of comic book
things that I could point to but because
it's all over the place
I don't want to speculate too much but
the whole thing from the Mark Waid era
is wall-e because he was the main
version of the flash wearing the red
costume during that era realizing that
if he were to achieve his full potential
like when they say that Wally's the
fastest version of the flash in the
comics in order to achieve that speed he
will effectively become one with the
Speed Force and he won't be able to be
with his friends anymore so that
probably has something to do with why
sabotage seems like he's slower now that
he is 100% physical in our universe like
he existed is this energy speed force
wormhole alien being it had limitless
power but now he's trapped in a physical
vessel so he's a little more beatable
than he was before but Barry is also
getting better and better with each
episode so just remember that no matter
how powerful savatage started out no
matter how powerful he is now very
always gets more powerful with each new
episode
really the biggest WTF below the show
could deliver is if it does like a big
Daniel West twist where the Salvatore
costume is kind of like the Daniel West
costume so that was new 52 he was the
brother of iris West
obviously the TV show has not done a lot
of that storyline has changed a bunch of
the characters in the way their powers
work Daniel West still exist during
rebirth but his costume just kind of
grows out of them and makes them look
kind of like a monster the way thats
avatar does so they're borrowing a lot
of aesthetics from that even if they're
not doing the Daniel West character but
just remember how personal savatage
vendetta against Barry is it's not like
they were just common enemies eobard
thawne is a lifelong enemy of Barry
Allen savat are talks about them the
same way the EO Barr talks about him and
there aren't that many characters in the
comics that have that personal
relationship with Barry even Salvatore
in the comics which is like this big bad
that they defeated and then he moved on
it really wasn't that personal he hated
the entire flash family equally but the
black flash I know a lot of you were
asking questions about that because I
doesn't look like his glove it could be
zoom because there are two characters
that wear black costumes they're zoom
and then there is the version of zooms
that became the black flash that has the
claws instead of gloves like it isn't
really freakish look to it so this could
be one of those two people but it just
seems like Barry is facing his demons in
the form of his friends and his foes so
I will go on record as saying that the
only person that I am 99% sure is its
avatar is not is Eddie I think of all
the people that we know now that could
potentially become savat are in the
future it's not Eddie it would have to
be somebody who's already a speedster so
you're talking about Jay Garrick you're
talking about Wally and it just feels
like if you're going to be picking
between those two then it would be much
more meaningful to make Wally the
speedster and I'm not even a hundred
percent that they would drag Wally
through the mud in that way it feels
like Favot are could be somebody that
we've never met before but because of
the way he exists beyond space and time
in the Speed Force that sort of shows of
the logic because Jay Garrick told us
the story that Salvatore is supposedly
the first person to be granted speed B
is a philosopher's stone so that means
that he was a speedster before Jay
Garrick was a speedster
but because john wesley shipp says
his character jay garrick has been the
flash for 20 25 plus years that would
makes avatar very old so just remember
there are a lot more questions for the
show to answer so they'll continue to
tease stuff out especially once we learn
more about what's up with the metal of
his suit that's probably going to
provide the biggest clues of all but for
those of you asking about flash rebirth
stuff I do totally think they could have
a Wally West returning flash rebirth
style twist whereby he manifests out of
the Speed Force if you haven't read the
rebirth story arc what happened is is
that pre flashpoint ginger Wally West
was retcon by new 52 into
african-american Wally West in the
comics sort of walked that back saying
that ginger Wally West never really died
he was just sucked into the Speed Force
and then finally made his way out but
because he didn't have a tether he
wasn't able to manifest physically so
his tether became Barry Allen Barry had
to remember him in order for him to come
back so it was a really trippy twist so
expect a version of that on the flash TV
show they'll get him out eventually like
they're not going to leave him stranded
in there but he might be stuck for a
little while and I'll be interested to
see if they're able to get him out by
the end of this next episode any time
something really big and crazy like that
happens they usually take it back pretty
quickly like when Barry got sucked into
the Speed Force he was back by the end
of the next episode
so I'm not expecting Wally to be stuck
in there too long but what will happen
is is because there's so many comic book
things that they could be pulling from
I'll wait till the next episode to do
Easter eggs and just talk about specific
concepts but if they're any bonus videos
you guys want me to do likes avatar as
the potential blue future flash then
I'll do that this weekend where you wave
that you can click here for my flash
episode with all the Easter eggs and you
can click here to learn all about the
Star Wars fails they scream this morning
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video
you